je partais dunkerque j'allais au havre
[ __ ] une sacrée belle histoire d'amour
c'est fini ah ouais c'est fini ça durait
combien de temps on chez plus dunkerque
le havre faut compter trois heures
myriam qu'elle s'appelait c'était par un
fusil de beauté mais [ __ ] j'y pense
souvent à myriam et je me dis que
peut-être c'était la femme de ma vie en
fait et retient et c'est pour elle que
j'ai fait ce tatouage
pourquoi aller aux jo je t'aime en
anglais ait un but à la voile à lorient
mais qu'est ce que je viens de te dire
pour tenter conquois toi mais à l'aube
j'aime beaucoup le à s'est passé c'est
un jeu non c'est bon je te dis mais
attention je sais par mois comme dans
les feux de l'amour enfin [ __ ] t'as
jamais dit je t'aime à une grossesse
quoi toi mais non mais je en anglais
monsieur séailles pas pourquoi cela
s'est passé
les initiales de chrétiens des [ __ ]
mecquois aïe la roue mais qu'est-ce qui
me veulent et de [ __ ] là dessus si tu
commences à me casser les couilles mon
coco et oh ça va c'est bon c'est pas ma
faute c'est une faute d'orthographe sur
le bras